Britain still shivering in the grip of a
cold snap weather warnings for snow and
ice now stretching across the country as
the Deep Freeze persists we're looking
at least another week of these really
cold Arctic conditions and although we
do get some lovely Spells Of Sunshine in
this wintry weather we have of course
all the usual winter hazards so we've
got sleet snow hail freezing rain
freezing fog it's impacting travel as
well as delayed trains and canceled
flights the roads are treacherous these
kinds of conditions particularly limited
visibility and ice can make car Journeys
much more difficult and dangerous and
it's why for many people across the
country Monday morning's commute is
likely to be an unpleasant one for lots
of people the plunging temperatures
means finding extra money to heat their
homes at an already expensive time my
heating bills are
I have a smart meter so I watch it go
every day it's not pretty the builds are
a bit concern I just hope there's more
money coming from the government because
lots of people are going to go bankrupt
you do worry about people that are
sleeping out and not be not being able
to keep warm it's particularly
particularly cold spell I think there's
another concern too the colder it gets
the more demand there is and amid a
global energy crisis the grid itself is
being tested unfortunately when you have
cold weather like this those cold
systems often come with still weather
and so at the same time as having
elevated demand you have less wind
generation to contribute so it's the
worst of Both Worlds the cost and
possibly even the availability of energy
yet another thing to think about as the
country battles to stay warm in their
run up to Christmas Hannah Thomas Peter
Sky News